two are very happy with you know he's
our starting quarterback
uh he did a nice job this year coming in
uh as a rookie with no off season and
and the challenges of dealing with all
that and um very happy with him and uh
looking forward to watching him progress
here over the next with an off season
here going into next year and
you know for us uh not really talking
about draft strategy anything right now
the season just ended if your desire is
to add competition and upgraded all
positions is quarterback part of that
calculus
yeah it's every position like i said
it's it makes everyone great i mean
there's been
history has shown doesn't matter who it
is you're always looking to bring in
guys that fit your system and then we'll
push people and make them better we also
want to be clear that tua is our starter
and we're very happy with this
development so far
it's so funny watching brian flores on
the other side of the screen while chris
greer is talking flor flores just wants
to get up and leave
he's not enough he's like damn it's been
i got all the dark grind all over here
he's like i've literally i'm riding and
i i've been in the dark grinding all
year i'd like to get out and enjoy
florida and see my family that's what
he's saying like come on hurry up
look i i i put no stock in anything that
is said during these perfunctory end of
season press conferences yes tua is
their starting quarterback i get it that
doesn't mean that they won't decide
based upon
upcoming events that someone else should
be their starting quarterback you can't
rule it out look at what the cardinals
did two years ago when they had taken
josh rosen with the 10th overall pick
trading up to get josh rosen in the 2018
draft 2019 first overall pick kyler
murray so when you hold the third
overall pick by virtue of the the larry
mutunsel kenny stills trade you hold
that pick now the texans were that bad
that's good for the dolphins you have to
evaluate all the quarterbacks you have
to because you may be trading that pick
to somebody who wants to come up and get
a quarterback so you need to be able to
negotiate properly and effectively the
terms of that trade and what better way
to do it than to have your own opinions
about who that quarterback's going to be
because they're not trading for the pick
they're trading for the player so in the
process of evaluating the player
maybe you decide
that player's better than the one that
you have and that's the way football is
they're always looking for someone
better than who they have they don't
come out and say it they want to have a
franchise quarterback that's going to be
there for 15 years
but
if they can get somebody better you know
they're going to do it chris yeah well
yes i mean especially if they think it's
like slam dunk better without a doubt
well and there's more leeway to do it
this day and age with the rookie salary
cap and not being tied to like a guy
you've never seen played for you know 70
million i've never seen him play but we
gave him 60 million guaranteed an 80
million dollar contract that's what was
crazy about the old way now you're not
you know your hands are not tied in
those situations
i do expect tua to be the starter though
i do
you know and cr this you know everything
i know mike that this was chris grier's
guy
he was the guy
you know i've heard from a lot of people
who i trust i've heard it was an owner's
pick i've heard it was an opening i i i
i've heard differently so i i don't know
either way chris greer screwed up
because he should have taken justin
herbert yeah well that's that listen at
the end of the day that's going to
continue to be evaluated almost like
trubisky with deshaun watson and mahomes
this is going to be the thing now the
one thing we know and it doesn't mean
it's like but this aspect this
conversation's over it's already over
justin herbert is
far more talented than to it that'll the
gap will never be closed that's not even
a discussion anymore there's nothing
there now the gap can be closed about
playing the position but you got to be a
little concerned with what we saw with
tua at the very least with the way
they've built their team and everything
like that
whether they need to bring in another
really quality backup like a ryan
fitzpatrick once again because they need
to do that just for the the to have the
backup plan to go wait we have a great
team again and oh it's just like last
year when we get down we can't really
trust our quarterback to drive or make
any plays or do anything like that so
they'll have to protect themselves with
that to a degree at least in my opinion
this off season
but the mere fact that i'm saying that i
know that you're saying that right i
know when else have we ever had that
caveat for a budding
franchise
high first round quarterback that wasn't
the conversation for josh rosen it
wasn't both they need to have a guy who
can come in if josh rosen urinates down
his leg during the game and we don't
know what to do and again it hurts me to
say it because i love two of the person
but two of the quarterback has
a long way to go
to catch justin herbert as you said and
to be who they expected him to be when
all the tank for two attack was
happening in 2019 and we thought the
dolphins were trying to get to the first
overall pick so they could get to her
and they end up getting him at number
five because of the injury issue and
they wanted to go up and get borough
folks they tried to move up to get joe
burlo and their fallback
was tua
and i don't know how seriously they
considered chris that their fallback
should have been herbert no i know i i
mean obviously you know you know it is
always a good conversation
i think this is the perfect a
conversation again and we don't know two
is still developing and there's nothing
wrong with not you don't have to be a
superstar you're one you can develop and
then become a superstar and be a great
quarterback and we don't know where
that's at yet but we do know he's got to
make adjustments to his game
and the way it looks right now again
is and this is where all quarterback
miss evaluations happen
tua was drafted with the thought of wait
uh he's coming with alabama right you
know guys are going to be wide open and
the protection's going to be perfect and
right that's the guy i'm getting oh no
you're not it's the nfl it's not going
to be like that you're not going to be
considerably better than every team
you're on the field with every week like
he was at alabama and that's where two
has got to adjust he's going to have to
addre adjust his you know uh his feel
for what's open how to be aggressive and
all of those type of things you know
like you've heard me say when brian
fitzpatrick comes in the football game
it's the same place to iran they're not
running a different offense it's the
same but you know open by four inches is
open in the nfl two is reluctant to make
those throws you know being able to step
into a throw even though there's people
around you that's a good pocket in the
nfl two doesn't want to do that he wants
to get out and get away before he has to
be so those he's got to make those
adjustments from what he thought college
to nfl life is like and then he can
improve from there but that's a big if
and we're going to see if he can do it
do you think the desire not to step into
the throws in the pocket is just a
residual of this
injuries and impact and trying to keep
himself safe and he's safer throwing on
the run outside of the pocket where he
knows when he throws he's not stepping
into the face of these giants who are
trying to destroy him i think there's
definitely a part of that yes i think
there was a conservative effort for him
this year
where he was like i'm not gonna let them
hit me i'm gonna try to stay healthy and
that could have played into that you
know that factor you're talking about
but you can't continue to play like that
forever you know because you're going to
leave completions and yards and plays on
the field if you're playing like that so
he's just going to have to get
comfortable hopefully yes health-wise
he'll be better and then he's going to
have to get comfortable
throwing in the trash as we would say in
the nfl with people all around you and
man it doesn't feel comfortable but man
that guy's open and your job is to get
him the ball and you got to figure out
the way to do that and that's where
we're not at quite yet and you know
again we'll see this is where i was a
little negative on them you know this is
the mistake we see repeatedly with
college quarterbacks you know the
matliners the tim tebows we just go oh
they win and the stats are great yeah
okay
yeah okay wait tim tebow threw it three
feet and percy harvin ran 70 yards matt
threw it four feet and reggie bush ran
80 yards and we went whoa what great
quarterback plan i want to go no the
coach just said throw it to that guy and
that's all they did that wasn't that
hard and that's where miss evaluation
continues to happen at the position
in his defense tim tebow completed 80
percent of his three-foot pass
yeah did
one last thing though
it this really is a painful discussion
for me because tua is awesome i know we
loved him last year when we interviewed
him i've talked to him
he's great his family's great he is a
great young man and we hope
that these issues
these areas of improvement get addressed
so he can blossom into a great
quarterback he would be an excellent
representative of the nfl for the next
10 15 20 years
we we want him to get there and if
you're a dolphins fan
i don't think
you
your interests are best served by just
burying your head in the sand and saying
well we just have to stick with this guy
hey we picked him over justin herbert we
have to stick with him no matter what
the reality nfl is they're always
looking for the next guy who's going to
be better than the guy they have and if
they can get him they need to do it
that's what's in the best interest of
the team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports